okay
yeah you know online channel yeah lovely
um do you want to hand over to john now
or anything thank you okay
yeah he's gone yeah okay guys
good morning everybody and good morning
to everest watching us on youtube
uh this is ons internal and we're
looking at our budget and
capital program um
where are we we'll get straight on to
the um
to the agenda then mary have we got an
appeal any apologies mary
yes joe we have apologies from
councillor inch councillor hurley is
substituting
and that's all that's all okay fine
thanks very much mary we're going to
item to the minutes
of the last meeting um
i'll i'll read the pages up page by page
paste page three page four
page five
page six page seven
and page eight could i have a proposal
please
i'll propose yeah you've got something
chair you've got a couple of hands up
i can't oh yeah i've got steve it's up
actually
ian yeah
did you want to say something here i did
yes
on page eight was i asked for an
explanation regarding the scoring and
waiting of pigs
it's supposed to be uh coming forth
coming on the 13th the 40th of january
meeting
right i haven't seen anything in the
report and i hope would actually have
something by now
okay i'll go back to
um let me just get just
wait while i get rid try and get rid of
the screen so i can see everybody
okay i will go back to steve steve
um chair we will need to have a look at
that
um it's something that needs
now needs a review obviously the the
council's updated its strategic plan
and pids and the assessment of which
should link to what's in your strategic
plan as part of the scoring mechanism
so it's a piece of work that um
david hayes and adrian redwood need to
do between them
we can circulate the current paid
documents if that would
uh help mr harper um but it
is somewhat out of date okay
ian is that okay yeah i'd prefer
something for today so we can actually
have a look when we're looking at the uh
um capital programme
but yeah that's fine thanks okay could i
have a second of them please for
for these minutes
okay there was another item i want to
pick up oh sorry steve sorry
sorry you didn't say there was two items
go on
just on page five with the home working
and
zoom meetings a piece of work that uh
the committees
asked is our hr commons manager to
uh to to progress yeah um just recently
circulated a questionnaire to all
members
um unfortunately thus far we haven't had
a very good response
um so we we need to kind of get a
reminder out to members because
you know your um views opinions
on homework well particularly on zoo
meetings
is valuable to that uh exercise
okay so you know we need to get a
reminder out
to all members to feedback otherwise
you're not gonna have
sufficient information uh to analyze
okay steve and i must admit i'm one of
them that hasn't
i forgot all about it anyway okay
could i have a seconder now then please
peter all right who's second it
tell me can't stream god
all right council god mary you've got
that
yes chair i have you ready for me to
read out the names yes please go to the
vote okay
council about and abstain
councillor hunkin or
mr dengate or councillor cup for
councillor haines for mr harper
or councillor harley
or council langford
for councillor newton
unmute simon
herrera can't abstain as i wasn't
present at that meeting thank you
and councillor watson yeah four
that's nine four and two abstentions
sorry eight four and two abstentions
i find that thank you very much mary
we've got item three
now the action list okay you've got a
hand up oh sorry
chris leather yeah thanks chairman uh
i'm not going to
fear just that this survey that steve
hurst mentioned
i noticed yesterday about that i've not
seen that so
i'm glad it's being sent around again
because i don't think i've responded
because
i don't remember having seen it before
i know i know i haven't responded but i
have seen it
and i forgot all about it to be honest
yeah just to confirm that
we um hr sent the initial email out and
we've listed it in the members bulletin
twice but all right all one of the team
sends out individually again
a lot of apologies coming in then okay
right we're going to the action list now
nobody else stand up no it's fine
action lists on page 9 to 11.
right okay we'll check the first one
minute 69 that is still ongoing um maybe
i don't know we'll have to decide
whether we want to take that off for now
or not
um but we'll leave it at the minute
um minute 53 15th of december that's
completed
yeah the second one for the 15th of
december that's completed
um the covid homeworking
and zoom meetings obviously then this is
what we've just been talking about
about the little survey that sarah would
like us to do
uh and
the minute 53 again
on 15th of december that's already
that that is with that one um
treasure minute 55 15th of december
treasury investment
uh options uh that one is still ongoing
um we can all read that there minute 56
review of the qbr task and finish group
meeting
group we have
it is completed because we have started
the task and finished group meeting
which will be having another one i think
it's next week
john yeah i think it's on
thursday this thursday
all right okay right okay then
so we've gone through the action list
any comments
about the action list peter ames um
yeah minute 55 about treasury
um investment options it says here
i wouldn't expect um policy to be
adopted
before the end of the financial year um
yeah can we have it explanation of that
i mean
you know that's part of the climate
emergency isn't it
well yeah if you want to call it that
can i ask david hayes and yeah david
sorry yeah i mean the policy we're going
to present a
a an amendment to our treasury
management policy which needs
approval by fall council on the 22nd of
february
so once we've got approval from full
council that we can do the ethical
investment
then the next time uh we do any
short-term treasury deposits
uh if they fall within the criteria
being within point two percent
will make a it'll be an ethical
investment so all i'm saying is it'll
follow the 22nd of february
which so i'm not saying it wait till
april it just depends next time
a we make a deposit
yeah which could be before the end of
the year um councilman's at the moment
our cash flow is um
quite fluid because we're holding monies
for all these business support grants so
i can't tell you when the first one will
be it could well be before the end of
the financial year but in all likelihood
it'll be around that time okay okay so
we just have to wait for formal approval
from full council before we can do that
because they're the
um body that can actually approve it
yeah just like
just interested to read a headline this
morning um
across university studies found fossil
fuels cause one in five deaths
worldwide so that relates very strongly
to what we invest in so i thought i'd
just tell you that
thank you thank you very much
um we've got a hand up and just to let
you know councillor manley's just joined
the meeting
all right okay council pennington
have you done any thank you chair have
you done any scoping around negative
interest rates and how that will affect
our funds
should negative interest rates kick in
later on in the year
thank you chair okay
do you want me to respond yes please
no no if the truth be told uh at the
moment we basically get
0.1.2 that's what we're getting um
obviously
if we've got negative interest rates
then it will be a financial penalty to
the council
um i can't they in the i'll come to it
the projections i'm making in the
medium-term financial strategy about
future interest rates but clearly
that isn't um my area of expertise
as a local authority section five one
officer
you know i'm not somebody who trades in
the city and
actively um estimates where the interest
rates be we just get the best interest
rates we can at the time
okay okay phil berrington yeah just
follow along with that can we just have
a guide you know every time we lose
point one of a percent what does that
mean to to to the reserves basically or
the deposits
well that would be fairly easy for us
and to work out
you know what the impact would be on our
reserves if we knew every time the
interest rates went down
okay david can't this come up in inside
your
presentation it does come up inside my
presentation and to be honest it's also
something that um we get addressed when
we do the qbr
internal overview and scrutiny but there
is i do reference the impact
of um the decline in interest rates has
had on the council's finances
in in the presentation that's coming
later council at pennington
thank you david thank you okay a chair
yeah okay
um okay then public contributions i
don't think we've got any have we john
uh no chat right
[Music]
did you i think david is going to do
this amongst his presentation
i think it's probably best to do it now
if truth be told if you want to david
yes i'll read that sorry as steve steve
hirst has alluded to i've got a letter
from great tarrington town council
and perhaps it's probably best if i read
it at this juncture
all right okay okay um it's from karen
chapman who's the town clerk of great
torrance and town council
i'm writing on behalf of great
torrenting town council
in support of great torrington's museum
i'm sure you're aware that the museum
currently exhibits from 14 south street
which is a great
torrington town council property and the
first and second four facilities of
market house which is a
torres district council property the
arrangement to lease the market house
was originally made with genesis
who also had an agreement with torrey's
district council to run the whole of the
market
area this changed in april 2019 when
responsibility
was passed back to torridge there's been
no official arrangement read market
house however
the town council paid rent to genesis
and latterly torres district council for
use of these rooms
on behalf of the museum this rental
charge was waived by turret over the
past year
primarily due to the lift not working
we are aware that funding was agreed in
recent years by torres district council
to
repair stroke replace upgrade the lift
which is one of the number of projects
allocated reserve funding
for the market at great torrington this
work has yet to be done
despite a number of site visits by td
satori's district council officers
and it seems now that there is an
intention to remove this works
from the capitalist for expenditure in
2021-22
the museum recently had a change of
chairman and enrolled a number of new
trustees and spent a huge amount of time
and energy
renovating the interior for opening in
2021
however the progress will be halted if
the lift does not work
as the museum have been able to open as
they will be in breach of equality and
disability legislation the town
cannot emphasize emphasize enough how
important this facility is for the local
community and beyond
in september 2020 the town council set
up a marketing group
with locals within the community we
recognize the identity of the town
is wrapped up with the heritage
environmental culture and small
independent shop network
and this is how we are promoting the
town we are currently working on maps
and we also have a heritage warp map
copy of this is attached
we will shortly have a town centre map
and a civil war trail map ready to go
for this year's season it would be a
travesty to the market
the town with such a strong emphasis on
heritage not to have the museum open
in addition to the above the museum is
also a key player
in a in a project being spirited by
spearheaded by tory's district council
the renovation and improvement plan for
the globe hotel
which will again be another significant
addition to the rich heritage of the
town
we would therefore implore you to honor
the initial agreement to repair the lift
at market house
and formally consider provision of
funding for this in your capital program
for 2021-22
we understand from the museum chairman
we understand that the museum chairman
has received a quote for the works and
it is in the region of three thousand
pounds
investment now would secure the
long-term project and the positive
impact and ramifications across the
local area
devon and devon as a whole and further
beyond thank you in advance for your
consideration of this request karen
chapman town platform
great torrington town council okay thank
you david
uh steve could you come
come back in on that please um yes
thanks
probably it's probably worth uh updating
i know we don't normally discuss public
contributions but it's probably worth
this time
updating members where we are with with
a request
um so it's it's something adrian redwood
major projects manager had already been
dealing with
and has been dealing with during the
course of this year
um the problem with the the lift
originates from the fact that the
the lift shaft is filling up with water
due to a problem with the
the drains there and that's what's
causing the
the problems with the lift so obviously
you couldn't
uh do the repair the necessary repairs
to the lift
until the works to the drains were
completed otherwise it would just
uh cause further damage uh so the works
to the drains have been progressing
through the year and i understand they
were finished
just before christmas um and i
understand from adrian and spit when i
spoke to him this morning
that that's uh solved the problem in so
far as the waters now directed away from
the the lift shaft
um so that that piece of work with the
lift has been
in there the program for the team to
deal with
it just had to be dealt with in the the
correct
order so now that now the drains have
been resolved
adrian the team will move on to look at
the works necessary
uh for the lift and whilst these figures
quoted in the the letter david just read
out
um obviously uh torridge um will have to
go
and procure those works ourselves i
don't know how much that'll cost
but that's already in the program so
members don't need
to consider adding this piece of work uh
to the program as it's already
encapsulated within it okay thanks
thanks steve uh cheryl yeah i was just
gonna say there was a letter
sent from the chair of trustees of the
museum dave gibbons
um sent to democratic services which i
forwarded
because it's not just about the lift
there were other issues within the
notice of motion that counts the bright
putt forward
so obviously it's good news that the
lift is in the program of works
but there's other issues as well which
need to be
looked at and fully considered as it was
passed as a notice of motion
previously and it looks like it's
there's there's a figure in the report
that says 220
000 pounds next to that notice of motion
but i haven't seen a breakdown of that
and i was somewhat shocked by it so oh
later on in the meeting i'll propose
that that should be considered
formally um and can
let it be read out from dave gibbons
because it was sent in
sorry can the letter be read out from
the chair of the museum because it was
sent in advance
okay if we've got it steve i'm trying as
i said in the chat i haven't got it i
think councillor cockthank it has since
circulated it but because we're on this
meeting i haven't logged on
david hayes as well he's got access to
his email
david have you got it
just unmute dave
it's probably easy okay i can read it
out i'd have to
look away from you because it's on the
other screen if you want me to read the
correspondence we might as well go go
through it now
yeah okay dear counsellors i should to
begin
with introduce myself i am the new chair
of torrington museum
i've been taking over as part of our new
team of trustees in september this year
our former torrent and town council have
been employed by the national trust for
15 years and work daily on the care of
historic artifacts and buildings
torrential museum currently occupies two
spaces 14 south street
owned on our behalf by great torrential
town council and the adjoining market
house the upper floor of the panu market
owned by torres district council since
we took up occupancy of the market house
torres district council has been
supportive
in allowing an access point to be built
and
most recently making rent adjustments to
our landlord great tarrington town
council
as a consequence of our enforced closure
due to the covid19 situation
we are appreciative of torres district
council's ongoing support
and enjoy working with you i have also
met with john
fallows and we have a positive and
constructive working relationship
as i understand it victoria district
council's long-term intention is that
great torrington town council will take
on a lease for the
market house so that so so that both
buildings can be managed together
there are however a number of obstacles
which need to be overcome before this
can happen
as at present the building is not in
good order and not fit to be open to the
public
counselor bright in putting a motion
before you and i should like to take
this opportunity to support it by
restating the existing issues which need
addressing
before any handover can take place
there is a history of structural and
mechanical failure with the lift
the bottom of the shaft is prone to
flooding and the
mechanical lifting mechanism does not
rent work rendering
it inoperable because the majority of
showrooms in the museum are on the first
floor
the market house being by far the
biggest it is in
its inaccessibility to visitors with
impaired mobility is a major problem
indeed a serious stumbling block to our
ability to reopen in 2021
all that is available to such sorry
david i think that was the
letter that was read out for councillor
bright's notification that the letter is
actually in the email
i have already celebrated councillors
it's the forwarded bit that says dear
counsellors and officers it's the actual
email
it says i note at your meeting you will
not be reviewing the decision oh okay
okay it just it talks about
the listing of the building and us being
the owner
okay okay
right okay i'll start again dear
councillors and officers i note at that
your meeting you'll be reviewing the
decision not to progress councillor
bright's motion of the 26th of october
2020
that works be carried out to improve the
market house and plan your market in
great torrenting
may i ask you to kindly reconsider the
decision and lie of the supporting
comments made to the council at that
time
my own are attached and the fact that
the motion was passed with 32
councillors voting in favor
including all those present today it was
stressed that the trustees of torrenton
museum consider the lift repair
not replacement to be the utmost urgency
the other works are important and
necessary
but as will be seen below lift without
the lift the museum cannot open
meaning no income and a loss of
considerable momentum and local
interest engendered by the new
management team's re-launch of it
they're in some additional points that
bear consideration too
which i will set out briefly as i can
the building is grade two listed
and currently occupied by torrenting
museum through great torrington town
council's rental agreement with torres
district council
has freehold owners regardless of
tennessee arrangement
torres district council remains legally
liable for its structural upkeep
where the building in private hand
torres district council would be able to
enforce maintenance works under section
54 and 55 of the planning
listed buildings and conservation areas
act 1990
in this case the enforcing of foreign is
also the owner which means historic
england is empowered to serve a section
54 notice
i am sure you agree with me that ongoing
and knowing neglect of a significant our
architectural asset would not reflect
well on its owners or the community
particularly if it had to be put onto a
building's at-risk register by historic
england as a consequence of the leaking
roof
unstable floor peeling paint and rotting
windows
works done now as a matter of urgency
will not not only fulfill the council's
obligation as owners of a public asset
and historic building but also prevent
further expense in the future of
continued deterioration
second point the lift installed in the
building was found into
needed repair in 2018 and a report
presented with a quote of just
under 2500 for remedial works it has
been
out of service ever since torrington
museum has commissioned a new
examination
and a quote which is attack is for three
thousand and eighty seven pounds sixty
pence
the lift is essential to providing
disabled access with the requirements of
the equality that 2010
as the bulk of the museum's displays are
upstairs and are otherwise only
accessible by staircase
in the lighter 0.2 above the trustees
note that the following
are to be found in july 2019 torres
district council's draft set of accounts
planned maintenance the council sets
aside 80 000
pounds on an annual basis towards
planned maintenance however has been
recognized as a significant pressure on
the budget in 2019-20 namely
replacement filter and pumps at the
council swim fields in holsworthy and
biddeford in addition serious
investment required to upgrade the lifts
of torrent and pan new market
and hillsworthy mana offices and
conclusions
the council has enjoyed a successful
year which has allowed it to reallocate
resources to area future demands such as
replacement filters and pumps at the
council swimming pool planned
maintenance
upgrades to lifts at turnington pannier
market in houseworthy minor offices
point free above shows that torres
district council has knowledge the need
for the works on the lift
in light of the inspections by asca
lifts limited on the third of february
2021
the the works would be by way of an
update to meet current legislation
rather than replacement
the system unit is still evidently
usable
and many years of working life left in
it this means spending three thousand
eighty seven pounds six depends
rather than approximately twenty
thousand pounds which approachment would
cost
i know you as councillors and officers
at tourist district council have only
the best interest for our community at
heart
the work needs the works need to work
the work needed to improve the building
with the lift as an urgent first
priority
is while substantial not necessarily
burdensome
and the net gain in terms of benefit the
town its heritage and the people will be
huge i strongly urge you to consider my
point
and if you need any further information
or would like to see the building
yourself then please do contact me and
i'm more than happy to help and this is
signed by david gibbons the chair of the
trustees
thank you okay thanks for that david
thank you
well i think we've heard from steve that
that the money is there to do
to repair the lift and i think adrian
is possibly that's one of his next jobs
steve
yeah um
chad would say it's one of his next jobs
obviously he's got a number of
priorities it's
in his work program so i wouldn't like
to say
it's going to be done by a date um i
then spoke to him this morning he said
he would go away
and have a look at the prices
he had for the work when it was quoted
last time although that was some time
ago i know there's
a quote within the pack but obviously uh
we have to do that ourselves as managing
that piece of work ourselves
adrian's going to come back to me with a
time scale so
we can update members once once we've
done that
but but there is money in the
maintenance fund to do this
already that's right there is okay
that's fine
okay if the if the money's already there
i mean
i don't see the reason why we should be
trying to put it there again
but okay cheryl um yeah can that be
added to the action lists
um to get a date of when that will be
fixed yeah when we come to when we come
to it yeah
and for the breakdown of everything else
that needs to be done that was on the
notification which equals 220
000 pounds how do we
i'd like to put that back to cnr because
we haven't seen the proper breakdown of
that
and then councillors can see what they
would like to fund and what they don't
it's obviously that it's not just the
lift there's the rotting windows and
there's the leak in the roof
and the peeling paint etc etc yeah yeah
okay
do i put that forward later in the
meeting as a proposal
there's a proposal to take that we're
not actually
we're not actually discussing torrington
uh on its own we
you know i i our purpose today is for
for the capital and
and and budget uh no i don't think
that but it's literally you could put it
onto an action list
and and then try and get it taken to
cnr but it's yeah it's listed in the
report
as a notice of motion that isn't being
considered
and it's got 220 000 next to it okay
well we'll look at it when we get to it
then cheryl thanks
thank you
steve yes i was just going to respond to
some of those points that counselor
called hankin made
um so yes it was a notice of motion that
was accepted by
full counsel um and that that motion
be discussed um within the realms of the
major projects
working group um obviously that info
that part of it was discussed at the the
member workshop
that took place a number of weeks ago
and that particular project uh didn't
gain
support which is why it wasn't included
as a recommendation
in the report to community resources on
the 25th
of january and that hasn't been
proposed as a recommendation from
community resources to be included
in the capital programme thus far
obviously if
councillor copperhunting still wishes to
propose that then there's still the
opportunity to do that
at today's meeting as um
as there will be the same opportunity at
full council on the 22nd of february
uh to propose that's included and that
will obviously be subject to members
uh voting whether or not to accept that
proposal from uh council culture should
she
put that forward uh the reason the
figures are so high
is whilst it talks in the notes of
motion about repairs
it's repairs and works to the roof
windows
electric and electric works which is why
the the figures
appear to be quite significant that's
adrian's estimate
of those works um that are required from
council bride's notice of motion
okay hey stacy
thanks chair i was just gonna flag up my
concerns that this isn't a gender item
for today
and and the difficulty that we've got is
the reason we put
items on the agenda so the public know
what's going to be discussed
and they can contribute i think this was
a public contribution
but there's nobody else has had the
opportunity to discuss or prepare the
report so
i'm just flagging up my concern that
we're getting way into a detail the
non-agenda item for today
yeah i totally agree with you stacy uh
and
i think we should leave it there to be
quite honest
gerald you can come back if you want do
you oh you've taken remove your hand
i'll bring it up later okay fine
right
no more public contributions
john no chair
right okay right we'll move on to item
five
declarations of interests you you all
know about the declarations of interests
and you know as we go on you if you have
one just you must declare it
uh urgent matters brought up with the
permission of the chair i
i haven't got any urgent matters um
item seven agreement of agendas
parts one and two well we've got no part
two
so now we're going to item eight which
is the median term financial strategy
2021 to 24 25 on pages 12 to 53
and we're going to receive david
with great anticipation
thank you chair for that introduction um
apology in advance for anybody who's
been on community and resources you're
essentially going to get the same
presentations ever so slightly tweaked
could i have the first slide please um
john
okay so what am i going to cover in this
presentation
i'm going to cover the impact of
colvid19
i'll do a bit of a refreshing where the
council actually gets its funding from
i'll talk about the 2020 21
2021 22 provisional local government
center was actually now the final local
government settlement but it didn't
change for torridge
um i'll go through some key themes and
assumptions i'll move on to the capital
programme
i'll alert members to some risk as
uncertainty
say where we are now and how we bridge
the gap and there are any
recommendations can i have the next
supplier please tom
i think what's doing it john yes sir
so i have covered 19 well it's been an
exceptional year for all local
foresters including torridge um in
purely financial terms our income from
fees and charges was hit by the various
national lockdowns in particular car
parking
which at the time of doing this
presentation i wrote this presentation
was half a million dollars it's probably
maybe closest to six hundred thousand
pounds now another income such as
planning however was sharply up so the
mixed bag
uh interest rates uh because of the bank
of england cut the interest rates at the
start of the pandemic from i think what
one percent to 0.1 the money that we can
gain from our
short-term treasury deposits has
declined by 125 000 that's the
point that councillor pennington made
earlier on um
torridge has been tasked with the
delivery of various transits of
government grants such as business
support grants track and trace
self-isolation payments hardship grants
and we've incurred some significant
expenditure pressures such as additional
protective equipment extra cleaning i.t
investment to facilitate home working
increased support to leisure which i'm
sure members
um i've been to many meetings about uh
and also we've had the admin burden of
actually administering the various
government support grants you know
extra overtime etc the next place
john please so just how unusual is the
financial year 2020 21 been
in pounds and pens well in a normal year
we normally spend about 16 million
pounds excluding housing benefits
i'm expecting this year that we're going
to probably spend in excess of 60
million
so we're going to spend through our
books three times more than in a normal
year
and obviously the majority of that is
because we're administering business
support grants on behalf of central
government
okay next slide please john
oh that all looks a bit messed up or
does it look messed up to everybody else
yeah okay well luckily enough i've got
the slide in front of me
um in recognition of the impacts of
kovid 19 the the government has
gave us some additional funding so we've
had
1.2 million pound in just expenditure
support grants
they've given us about a third of a
million in what they call new burdens
grant so that's recognized the
additional workload we've had to take on
administering the business support
grants on them track and trace payments
for people isolating hardship etc
and we're also being compensated partly
compensate for our loss fees and charges
however we're projecting a surplus for
torridge
and that's largely because of a few
reasons one is
all these additional new burdens work in
terms of administering the business
support grant
the council has um borne that through
its existing results we've not gone out
and recruited additional staff
uh there's been a low incidence of
covert uniting we've been the lowest
within england
for the whole of the pandemic which
meant compared to some other councils
we've had low
back filling of pulse like particularly
into richard's area of refuge and
street cleansing we actually had a
significant while our plaque in the
income has gone down we had a
significant bounce back in the summer
months as people did staycations they
couldn't go abroad on the holidays
so they visited north devon we've had an
exceptional year
in planning income one i don't think
we've seen in
recent memory we're 400 grand above
target that's against a budget of 540 so
we've almost
doubled our planning income and we've
been proved it in the use of our
resources we haven't just thrown money
at the problem and if you've seen all
the negotiating in front of our leisure
provider
um you know they've had to make their
case to get additional support
uh next slide please tom john
right okay so we're all focused on covid
19. it was
it's easy to forget well we still got to
deliver our normal services
and raise the revenue to fund them you
know we still got to clean the streets
pick up the waste
do food inspections our public
conveniences our leisure facilities
collect the council tax cut the grass
none of them have gone away we've still
got all our functions and services
next slide please john
okay right so you've got two um boxes i
know
i'm trying to explain what they mean the
one on the left the pie chart
is showing how we get our money so we
just ignored in this year with all the
government grants that we've had for the
business support grants in a normal year
38 of our income comes in from fees and
charges
27 comes in from council tax business
rate retention is 25
an actual central government grant only
makes up 10
the chart to the right shows the trend
and i'm colour blind so i'll tread
carefully but i think it's the orange
line
which is the government grant line if
you can see the one that's going down
started back in 2013
about 4 million has now reached about
1.5 million
that's the number david is it green
thank you
councillor watson for enlighten me on my
color blindness thank you
much appreciated now in the
text in red which i'm fairly confident
is read
um income from fees and charges and
council apps are the two biggest
components
they're both areas where members can
make decisions that ultimately impact on
the revenue screen for the
revenue the council can generate okay
next slide please john
so the provisional local government
settlement is actually the final local
government settlement so you may hear
in the press that the corps spent
local authority set to increase by 4.5
that's a headline figure for torridge it
was zero
okay 85 of the increase in the core
spending power
of councils which government has
announced is due to inc councils
increasing their council taxes
up to their referendum limits so the
core spending power
in case of revenue support grant rural
services delivery grant which we get
because we're a rural forest and it cost
us more to deliver our services in a
very rural area
retain business rate income and section
31 grants
new homes bonus income something called
lower tier services grant that's new for
this year
and part of that is to protect us from
not being zero because we've lost so
much new homes bonus and i'll refer to
that later on in the presentation
social care grants of course which are
not applicable to us they're applicable
to the upper tier authorities such as
devon county council
and our council tax income but 85
percent of that 4.5 percent
is down to councils increasing their
council tax up to
their maximum next slide please john
okay so i'm just summarizing the various
grants that we're getting from central
government
so the first one you can see revenue
support grant
we're basically getting the same as we
got last year there's no change
the next one the rural services delivery
grant
you can see a very modest rise it's 497
please 478
000 but very modest right the next grant
new homes bonus
um last year we got 924 000. this year
we're going to get 381
000. so that third bar chart you can see
how much
it's just dropped off it's a dramatic
drop
the new grant that's coming the lower
services to grant
we didn't have any of that it's a new
grant we've got 297 but as you can see
that's not making up the shortfall that
we suffered on new homes bonus
and we've had some additional funding
for homelessness
and essentially without an increase to
up to the council tax referendum
torres would see a significant decline
in its core spending power
so our actual grant from government have
declined by 183 000 pounds
core grant next slide please john
that looks massively different on my
screen but there you go
um so the local government's out and
assumes that councils and precepts will
increase their council tax up to their
referendum rate so for devon county
council
that's two percent plus a three percent
social care preset for the devon county
commonwealth police that's 15 pound for
a band d property which is equivalent to
six point eight percent
devin summit set fire two percent
torridge
and we are allowed to operate by five
pound for bandy which is just under
three from two point nine six percent
and the town and parish councils there's
no referendum limits for them
if i assume a two percent increase for
town and paris councils and that all the
other precepts will raise their charge
up to the referendum limits then a bandi
property would rise
increase would be 95 pounds and six
pence of which torridge's share
is five pound it looks very different on
the on my chart but what you can see
there's a very thin line which is in
yellow
so what i'm trying to illustrate there
regardless of what we do
we're going to whatever we do is going
to be a very small percentage of the
increase that our residents will have to
bear
and i expect the other preceptors to
raise their charges
up to their precept limits referendum
limits
have the next flight please john
um and this is i think councillors will
be fully aware of this
we may be the billing authority so it's
our name on the bill that goes out to
our residents
but our share of the council tax bill
has been in long-term decline
every year our share goes down i think
we're hovering now around 8.4 percent
so we are only a very small contributor
to the bill that people ultimately have
to bear
next slide please right
because of the rules of um local
government
all council tax increases and when we
get to full council
in february the council tax resolution
will talk about a bandy equivalent
and that's just we just have to work in
them that's the way we have to work
however it needs to be recognized that
when we're talking about bandy the
majority of our resident lives in
properties
bands a to c 68 of them
and therefore would actually pay less
than the five pound increase that we're
proposing
an increase in the council tax of five
pound per band the equivalent
equates to less than 10 pound a week for
85 percent of our residents anybody who
lives in
bands a b c and d the increase
weekly increase would be less than 10 10
pence a week if we raise the charge by
five pounds
so that's just to give some scale to the
minimal burden that we'd put on our
residence shall say
next slide please tom john
um at the next slide i'm really
hammering on the council tax i don't
know if you're getting the theme
um in previous years members made a
decision not to increase council tax in
some years and
in some years a council was compensated
by receiving non-recurrent council tax
freeze grants
the graph below shows the impact of not
raising the council tax in prior years
up to the referendum limits and then
there's a consequence to that
so that means because we didn't raise
the council tax in prior years
cumulatively we've far gone three
million pounds
and if we had raised our council tax up
to the referendum limit in each year
we'd be about 440 000 pounds a year
better off
because when that grant from the
government went away because it was
non-recurrent in nature
we can't go back and make good the
increases we didn't approve
so what i'm trying to say is there's a
long-term impact of not deciding not to
increase the council tax
grab the next place please john
okay so key assumptions
council tax generally the collection
rate in torridge is between 98.5
and 99 with very modest changes from
year to year
however the projected projected
collection rate for the current
financial is 96.5
and we're projecting reduced collection
rates for 2021.22 to 97.45
due to the impact of colvid19 with an
increase in the collection rate there
after a half
percent up to 2024 25 when i'm
forecasting that the collection rate for
council tax will be back to 98.95
the immediate term financial strategy
that i'm presenting to you assumes that
council tax will
increase in line with its referendum
limits over the life of the median term
financial strategy
business rate well 2000 2021 was a very
strange year for business rates because
in reaction to the
covered 19 pandemic central goat amounts
various business rate reliefs
most notably retail relief as a
consequence the collectible business
rates in 2021 2020 2020 21
with intolerance declined from about 12
million to four and a half million
so we almost didn't have to collect two
thirds of the council tax
so because that all the retail
facilities weren't charged business
rates and a lot of the leisure wasn't
charged
um any business rates the government at
the time of writing
hasn't announced what reliefs there will
be for 2021-22 however
the government has said it'd be a good
idea not to send out your business rate
bills
prior to listening to the chancellor's
budget
on the third march which would be a fair
indication
that there'll be an extension in some
form to business rate release
so my budgets are seeing a very very
modest increase in the collectible
business rates over the life of the
medium-term financial strategy
it needs to be born in mind that whilst
we've collected less business rates
we've been
compensated by central government by
section 31 grants
so we've not lost out because we're
collecting less business rates
next slide please john
so get me over at key assumptions um
like i said i'm not somebody who deals
in interest rate movements i'm not
making great forecasts
uh the bank of england cut the base rate
at the start of the colvid19
found out which would dramatically
reduce the interest income the council
could earn on its short-term investment
just for the purpose of the median term
financial strategy
i am not forecasting that interest rates
will return to the pre-kovid 19 levels
in 220 until 25-26
that is just purely an estimate on my
part i have no greater insight
income from fees and charges the median
term financial
strategy assumes fees and charges at
their 2020
21 budgeted levels excluding car parking
and garden waste which is discussed
later in the report
the ongoing impact of coffee 19 in a
fees and charge is unknown
the government compensation scheme for
loss fees and charges has been extended
to june
2021 so we do have some protection if
our fees and charges are below budgets
for april may and june at this juncture
the spending review announced a freeze
on public sector pay
with the increase in the national debt
rising fund upon the pandemic further
restrictions on public sector pay can be
anticipated
now technically local government isn't
part of the public sector pay
freeze however we've not been received
any funding to fund any pay award and i
would expect that the local government
association in
negotiations in the union would
not want to give a pay award because it
knows that local authorities have not
been funded for a pay award so my
forecast is that for 2020
21 22 there'll be no increase in the pay
award except for employees on less than
24 000 pounds per year
it will get an increase of 250 pounds
and then for 2022-23 i've assumed a 1
increase twenty four 2023 point five
percent increase in two thousand twenty
four twenty five
two percent increase of course i'm i
could be wrong on this
this is just my best conjecture at this
juncture uh net supplies please john
just one sec can i have a drink while i
yeah you're talking for too long
okay mate it's been recognized as
members be aware that leisure's
particularly badly hit by kovid 19
and will face significant challenges
going forward
it's difficult to ascertain how long the
covid19 restrictions will be in place
and to watch then customers will return
to our facilities
consequently i've added another 150 000
per annum
in the budgets to reflect the increased
costs of providing leisure facilities
across torridge next slide please john
okay so where do i where after
accounting for the pressures
um so obviously we've got a cap some of
some of the pressures are capital
related
and we've got reduction in our new homes
bonus which
is about seven hundred thousand pounds a
year uh
we have we've got some funding shortfall
on our new environmental center
170 000 pound we come to that later in
the presentation
and we acknowledge that we need to make
more ongoing
contributions to our capital budget for
the renewal of our cap
actually resurfacing and general
maintenance we say that's 180 000 pounds
we've obviously got some revenue
pressures and just some of them is like
the loss of income from our short
certain treasury deposit because the
decline in the bank of england
um interest rates and obviously the
anticipated additional costs
of leisure 150 000 pounds
so the charts at the law you see the
blue figures are the deficit i'm
forecasting now
on the red figures with the deficit i
was forecasting
uh full council back in february 2020
and you can clearly see
that the position is significantly
worsened can i have the next slide
please john
right the the council has a
transition in government funding reserve
and this reserve is used to balance the
council's revenue budgets until either
expenditure savings are found or
additional revenue streams are
identified
and the projected use of this reserve
based on the deficits
i've identified on the previous slide
are shown below
so as you can see what actually happens
is in 2023
2022-23 we've nearly exhausted the
reserve
and in 2023 24 we're then in a deficit
position so
in very simple simplistic terms the
building society account we set aside
for the rainy day
has been exhausted by 2023-24
that money runs out so that money that
we use to
give ourselves time to get the budgets
back into kilter has been exhausted
quite quickly
okay can i have the next slide please
john
okay so now going to move on to the
capital
okay and both members here
were probably been at the member
eventually you would have seen some of
these slides before and some
and saying that would have had some of
the themes discussed
okay so the capitals program
for this tourist district council is 23
million
and there's a funding gap at 2.2 million
before the council adds new capital
projects and addresses the funding
issues pertaining to the proposed
environmental center
and it should be noted that only seven
and a half million of the funding is
actually held in the bank so to speak
so if you look at the chart below we've
got um an approved capital program of 23
million and the 7.7 million
safely tucked away in our reserves our
capital receipts
then we're forecasting additional
contributions let me just go
on a slap of 8.2 million now some of
this is
what we put aside every year towards
replacing our refuge fleet we put over
half a million pound a year
some of this is um expected funding from
um
sale of capital receipts and some of it
is grant funding
we've also then got another gap a five
million another contribution to bridge
the gap of five million which is
approved borrowing
however i'll alert to later on borrowing
has to be funded
from the revenue and that means we've
got a gap of 2.1 million as we said
that's before adding anything new
and addressing the environmental center
have the next slide please john
okay so why do we have a funding gap
of new capital before the consideration
new capital on the funding environmental
center well there's really two main
factors
uh constructs industry build inflation
so we put up
something in the capital program and
then by the time we get around to doing
it inflation is
adding to it in terms of the constructor
industry inflation is greater than
normal inflation
but one of the clear things is the
decline in new homes bonus
if you look back to 2016-17 you can see
that we got just over two million pounds
in
new home bonus which meant we could set
aside one million towards our capital
program
if you move forward to 2022-23 it's
essentially
disappeared so compared with
2016-17 we're one million pound a year
worse off in terms of funding of our
capital programme
and quite clearly that's had an impact
cover the next slide please
okay so we've got a funding gap
there's a bar chart there so we've got a
funding gap for 2.2 million
and then we've want to add in a rolling
program and the rolling program is
putting more money aside from our
revenue but it's to recognize that we've
always got
a cycle of maintenance and i think it's
a hundred and eighty thousand pound year
which over the terms of the medium term
financial is nine hundred thousand
pounds
to give some context to that in our
final accounts
the value of the council's london
property portfolio
is 38 million so to put aside
now some of that is land in fairness but
to put aside
900 000 just for the ongoing maintenance
of your existing assets over a five-year
period
is not excessive okay
then we need to add in a leisure
contingency of 330 000 because we see
that when we there's got to be a
schedule of work that we need to catch
up with before we renew the leisure
contract
and then we want to add um in the
environmental center
um shortfall of 1.5 million so the um
estimated cost of the environmental
center is now increased so we need to
recognize that increased costs
and then we've got the works at the town
hall roof
of 760 000 and all those things added
together mean that the funding gap that
i start we start with a 2.2 million has
actually risen to 5.7 million
before we address it can i have the next
slide please john
so how are we going to bridge the
funding gap on the capital programme
well we can break it down into three
elements
we can let's see if we can how do we
bridge the
um existing capital gap for 2.2 million
plus the leisure contingency in the town
hall roof that's three million
then we'll address how we can address
the environmental center the increased
cost there
and also the rolling program works where
we set money aside
to maintain our existing property
portfolio the 38 million that i alluded
to on the previous slide so can we move
forward john please
okay
so we've got an existing shortfall of
3.2 million
we however i've got some savings on the
existing capital program most notably
the borough center we've managed to get
external funding
which has made it's diminished our
contribution to the scheme so we believe
we can claw back over
half a million there and there's some
other amount of projects we're thinking
for like 140 000
we've got some capital receipts that we
know are coming are hopefully coming
cleave wood tadworthy hopefully bridge
buildings
west foothold park we've actually
received so however i think we need to
put a contingency we might not receive
all of those capital receipts and they
may be future
project initiation documents future
capital bids so we're taking off 500 000
i'm also saying we'll make a
contribution from this year's
surplus on our revenue budget to 642 000
and in the forecast um i'm forecasting
to make a contribution of
275 000 from the 2021-22 revenue budgets
and as you can see there essentially
with a fair wind
particularly on those capital receipts
we can bridge the gap
we can eliminate that particular
component
of the capital shortfall can i move
forward um john please
okay right the environmental center
right well we've got additional costs of
one and a half million pounds
and therefore we'd have to borrow
there's somebody in the um
we've already got some money sets out
but that mean we'll have to our
borrowing crime will have to increase to
5.6 million
the annual cost of servicing 5.6 million
pounds worth of borrowing is just under
400
392 000 uh we've identified savings and
increased revenue for having an
environmental center that is essentially
is selling on
um the recycling material that would be
sorted
on at the environmental center so that
would negate some of that pressure
still leaves us with an additional
pressure of 170
000 pounds per year so how could we
uh meet that gap well one way of meeting
that gap would be increase our garden
waste charts by five pound per year over
the next three years
which would generate another 180 um
thousand pounds per annum
um and there's a table to the site we
showed that currently we are the
cheapest
in um devon and our colleagues at north
devon have actually
increased their charge by four pound
four next year
um c r on the 25th of january approved
these increased garden waste charges
net slide please john
okay so how do we address the rolling
program
so we believe we need to set aside
another 180 000 pound a year
to have a proper maintenance budget
available for our existing portfolio
portfolio of properties as i've said
before i mean that
in our accounts that's 38 million
granted some of that's land so it's
quite a significant
property portfolio the council has for
us its size
so how did we think we could address
that well we thought we could address
that by increasing our car parking
charges
and that alluded to and spread over
three years
um focusing in the tourist areas which
would be appledore and westwood hall in
our town centres
and some of our other parking charges
such as um permit season permits
resident permits etc
so increasing the car parking charges
over three years would allow the council
to set aside significant funds to meet
its anticipated demands and maintain its
existing property portfolio
while contributing towards the revenue
pressures identified in the medium-term
financial strategy
and commuting resources on the 25th of
january improv approved these increased
parking charges can i have the next
slide please top um john
okay right so i do want to touch
on risk and uncertainty um
we've been in a bit of a halfway house
for a little while now due to both
brexit
and the kovid 19 reform of local
government finance has been delayed
for quite a few years now i think
probably in our third year delay
and the key elements of the reform of
local government funding are what's
called the comprehensive spending rule
in very very simple term that just says
how big is the pot for local government
compared with the nhs compared with
defense compared
with benefits the environment
agriculture and fisheries example so the
commentary and friends review
would say how big should central
government's funding of local authority
sector be
then the fair funding review says what
share the cake would authorities like
torridge get
and quite clearly a council a unitary
like birmingham city council would get
far more
um central government funding than
torres district council both because of
its population
because of the increased
responsibilities that our unitary has in
terms of children services social care
etc there's also flagged a review of the
business rate retention system
and a replacement for the new homes
bonus system
now i've just got a graph there and what
i want to say i mean this was here
last this time last year but it does
bear recognizing
since the introduction of local business
rate retention share districts
of torridge have benefited the most from
it because we retained 40
of the business rates and we've got low
need we don't have social services
education etc
however the counties have done
relatively poorly out of it because they
only keep nine percent of the business
rates
and they've got high need because they
have the social care and children
services
so i think it would be expect that when
they review the business rate retention
scheme
that there wouldn't be some
redistribution of resources from shire
districts to unitaries and to
the shire counties so that's what that
arrow is showing it is a flow of money
at some point in the future
when the reform of local government
finances comes in
so that is a risk to the risk to
torridge and to shy districts generally
can move forward please john
so what are the risk and uncertainties
well there's a longer term impact to
covet 19.
amazingly enough within turrish we've
seen a very very low
increase in the rate of claims for local
council tax support
we seem to be one of the anomalies um in
the country if i'm being perfectly
honest
uh we see we will see increase empty
business rate relief and i think at the
moment we may be in some ignorance
because
because of all the covered reliefs that
have been offered for businesses
there may be some businesses out there
which are empty which would normally
claim empty business rate relief which
would have to be borne by the council
but they haven't claimed it because
they're not having to pay business rates
anyway and i think once we come out of
the pandemic
uh i think there'll be an increase in
empty businesses
which we have to give empty business
free has to be funded by the council
in the first instance we've got to
recognize that people may be on reduced
income so there may be some collection
issues for council tax but okay at the
moment some people are on furlough
which may sound good in that you're on
75 your salary for not actually working
but if you live from paycheck to
paycheck that drop in your income could
cause you
some financial hardship and perhaps
we're not at the top of the list for
some people
in terms of paying their financial
responsibilities
i don't know what the impact on fees and
charges long term is going to be
i don't know if we're going to go to a
place where there's increased working
from home and therefore there's less
footfall in our town centres
so there's less car parking income for
example in our town centres in the long
term
and going forward the government will
clearly have to do something to reduce
to the national debt because of how much
they've had to fund the covid pandemic
and one way would be to reduce the
funding it gives to the local authority
sector
and i don't know how long the interest
rates will remain
low i've made an assumption the median
turned financial strategy they will
bounce back by 2025-26
that is just an assumption you know i do
not know i'm not the oracle and i don't
know which way interest rates will go
can i move forward please john
okay so after the cnr
approved both the increases to fees and
charges both garden waste and car
parking
the uh revised medium-term financial
strategy improved so if you see the blue
figures
this is what i'm projecting now compared
with what i was projecting in february
2010
and as you can see we actually get back
into balance on the budgets in 2024
25. in terms of the utilization of the
transition in government funding reserve
uh if you remember one of the previous
slides that was exhausted in 2023
24 it now shows that we've actually got
a balance there
and i think it's important to note that
that balance would be very important to
the council to manage the uncertainty
i've just alluded to on the previous two
slides in terms of the impact longer
term impact to covet 19
and the local government reform the
local government finance reform which is
coming
so it'd be sensible and prudent the
council to keep a healthy balance on its
transition in government funding reserve
and by the changes that have been
approved by cnr in terms of garden waste
and car parking
that allows us to do that going to move
forward john
okay so this is what the recommendations
and their rationale
so so the recommendation is that members
of internal over include
overview and scrutiny recommend to full
council
torridge vandy council tax for 2021-22
be increased by five pound
from 168 pounds 66 to 173 pound 66
and the rationale is that recognizes
that council taxes the
council's most stable source of funding
central government assessment of course
spending power assumes that we're going
to increase the council tax so we're
only doing what the government assumes
we will do
the responsibility to provide long-term
options on managing the council's
finances
and also our external auditors will
review torridge's going concern and
financial
sustainability so they will ask
questions if we haven't increased our
council that's how we're going to bridge
the gap by not doing
um it's just to note that the net
revenue budget for 2021
22 is 6.956 million that's just a
specific requirement that's a legal
requirement that we need to note that
and that we also note the contributions
to reserve
in 12.4 of the report that's a specific
requirement as well
and that the new projects identified
appendix one of the capital approved and
added to the council's approved capital
programme and that recognises that the
council has both ongoing capital
maintenance obligations
and pacific capital expenditure
commitments so for example the town hall
roof
and setting money aside to the ongoing
maintenance of our
existing property portfolio um can move
forward john
oh i've made a rod for me on back i've
opened it up to questions
oh there you go david i'm sorry it took
so long i do apologize
no it's fine mate you have another drink
now
anybody got any questions ah we've got
uh
peter aimed okay oh thanks joe
yeah i'd like to thank david for an
excellent presentation
thank you very much there's been a huge
amount of work to do that
um i was just interested in the huge
large amount of money for the town hall
um whether sort of an investigation has
been made
as to whether biddeford town council
could contribute to
the repairs to the roof given that they
use the town hall i believe
and whether sort of any investigation as
to an alternative
to the meeting place to the town hall
and in terms of whether we should be
selling this asset
or not asset um as it must cost a huge
amount of money to run and it's not used
very much
um i think i think the issue we have
there council claims is that we
inherited this from the reorganization
of local government back in
1974 and the building is a listed
building um
you know maybe i've been a bit crude
here but i don't really see in the
interest of biddeford town council to
want to take it on because
they'll be taking on quite clearly a
substantial financial liability which
unfortunately resides with us at this
juncture
and the fact it's a listed building
really inhibits us
as well in terms of our flexibility i
meant biddeford town council
contributing to the repairs
not taking it on sorry okay
um i don't think they're obliged to
i know agent's looking to see if he
could get any uh
any other sources of funding to
contribute to or you know if somebody
and historic england et cetera that kind
of route but um i don't think we've
identified anything at this juncture
okay thank you
any more questions ah yes please
simon go on uh can i just follow on from
peter holmes that very well placed
question now
um the town hall
do biddeford um rent their space from us
or pay proportionately for their space
um david in any way no
okay um
if and surely um
you know i mean i noted that they're not
they're not
short of money um they
they should reasonably um
if it's not just um throwing throwing a
contribution
then we can turn around and say right
fine okay then let's quantify that
differently
um they should they should lease or
or or rent um their space
off us um because we've got to run the
thing and it's quite reasonable to say
that there must be a contribution
um i mean at the moment they're getting
that cake and eating it
so if i can just come in there simon
we did this um a few years ago at ons
and we found that um oldsworthy
is the same and i think torrington is
the same we pay for everything
i think we even pay for the electorate
on on these places and but we
and i think steve might be able to
answer this
i don't think we can we can make them
pay
for anything can we steve um
no chairs as david uh pointed out
under the reorganization of local
government in 1974
we were obliged and required to for the
provision of office space
uh for those town councils uh so whilst
we can ask the question would you like
to pay something towards it um
they're not none of the town councils
are obliged to do so
um you know that our only alternative
would be to move them to other
premises um but equally that's only
shifting the problem we still
would have the problem of it being the
town hall a listed building in
our ownership so we'd still be required
to do the necessary works
and provide the town council
accommodation at
our cost somewhere else so it would just
um make the problem
even even greater it is
it is a common problem across local
government
um particularly where these provisions
exist
where um districts and other councils
are required to provide accommodation
for town
and parish councils under that that
particular act
chair we we did try this a few years ago
simon yeah well it's it it's frustrating
i mean not only not only from a
financial point of view
but most of these buildings are not
actually fit for purpose uh
nowadays anyway uh and um
they're just becoming uh and it's it's
their money ultimate i mean it's still
the same taxpayers pocket that all this
money has happened to come out of
um and and so it's um
becoming a real drag um on
the the local communities in a way i i
just think that
we should never give up trying to take a
forward-looking
fresh approach i have no time for people
who just
look back and say well that's how it is
and this ancient building is part of the
thing well
one's got to constantly reset and look
we're in different
times we're in a different culture we're
in a
completely different funding situation
and therefore
i think one's got to continue to
challenge i accept the
the the criteria and the limitations
that steve
points out there but um that doesn't
mean we shouldn't give up
um and anyway um a lot of these places
as i said aren't particularly fit for
purpose i didn't think in the modern
modern day but
that's my rant i'll i'll lay off
right okay then um
cancel ackee you want to say something
not war and peace
and not war and peace but um what i i
would say is that
we've we should never ever give up on
our heritage
you know this country has got a very
rich heritage and it all depends on what
we do locally to preserve and enhance it
but the question i have is of uh
david hayes now i
i heard him say about the fact that
by not putting up council tax some years
ago
we are in a much worse position now than
where perhaps
we could have been could he just go over
those figures once again
yes that's fine council hackett i'll do
that what happened um
i think it was back around 2010 2011
2012 maybe even into 2013-14
what the government did is he said to
councils if you do not put up your
council tax we will give you so
i think john may be trying to find the
slide um
we will have it here in front of me oh
very good oh no no
it's coming back through i'll tell you
when john
um keep going keep going
i think there you go so essentially what
happened was the government said to
councils
we will give you a grant if you do not
put up your council tax but the troubles
the grants were non-recurrent
so in year one if the council could have
raised say another 120
000 pounds of income from raising its
council tax it may have received a grant
of a hundred thousand or a hundred and
twenty thousand
i know the next year the government
repeated the same exercise we don't put
your council tax up again we'll give you
another grant well of course what
happened was then
that's one hundred and 000 then another
120 that's 240 000.
and you do that for three or four years
and then the government those grants
then fell away because they were
non-recurrent they weren't mainstream
they weren't recurrent you lost that
grant
and you lost that opportunity of the
council tax that you would have raised
so
so i'm estimating that um we're about
440 thousand pounds a year
wait quite just i think three three four
years of council tax not going up
and this is an accumulator every year
you've forgotten that 440 000 and
accumulative because it goes up and up
and up
it's trying to get the point is that
once you make a decision one year not to
increase the council tax you lose that
120 000 pounds 130 000 pounds
not just for this year but you use it
that for the every year going forward
and we can never go back in time
because of the referendum limit we can't
go back and say oh we didn't put it up
so instead of putting it up by five
pound per band day this year we'll make
good and we'll
raise it by ten pound and catch up we
don't have that facility because of the
referendum limits
so it's for members really to understand
there's a longer-term impact from just
this year
whatever decision they make on council
tests if they make a decision not to
raise council tax this year
the impact of it will be felt for the
life of this council
and councils to come thank you right so
where would we
be do you have the calculation where we
would be
if we had put it up yeah in those years
where would we be now on your graph
would be 440 000 pound a year better off
and that was when what james morris
would leave it wasn't it
i it's before my time council hackett so
i couldn't
no no i'm not getting political i'm just
sort of putting myself in historical
context pete
okay that's fine right thank you very
much that's
okay great brilliant thank you all right
sit back now phillip
i'll sit back dave early
thank you chair um i was going to just
say
exactly what steve hirst said not as
eloquently how the district counts are
responsible for
providing accommodation if you like for
the town councils etcetera
um and we could ask them
to contribute to the costs but obviously
they likely say no because we are the
landlords
and what council hackers referring to is
something that came about in the last
administration
where the government paid for for
consecutive years
and as david hayes rightly says we have
lost
uh the council taxing what for those two
years we lost all that money
it was a last administration not
previous administrations that agreed
to take that money therefore we are to
blame if you like
thank you chair yeah
okay anybody else got any questions
ah stephen dengay guy steve
just david thank you for the
presentation just a quick
kind of observation really can we think
about
and we i know we do monitor these but
sensitivity checks around the
the increases to the parking into the
green bins to make sure we don't see a
a downward turn and you know if we can
be monitoring to make sure that
we've got site that if it happens
because obviously it's going to be a big
it's going to be an important factor
going forward
yeah i mean the sensitivity on garden
waste will be quite easy to quantify
because we just have the number of
people who renew
so that'll be quite easy we'll be able
to see the people who
didn't renew because it went up by five
pound that's quite easy to do
i mean the car parking one's going to be
a little bit more tricky because of a
variety of factors in terms of
last year our income the summer months
worth of crazy months in terms of the
amount of income because of the
staycation
you know what would have his position
this year in terms of that you know
where people go abroad well not people
go abroad
but also car parking within turrets
particularly in the summer months
is very much weather dependent if the
weather's good
people go to westwood oh and appledore
you know a good summer can make quite a
big difference
so it'll be quite tricky to
unpick that would probably be easier in
the towns than i would imagine within
the tourist
locations i wouldn't be able to say how
easy it would be to unpick the impact of
the
increased charges on numbers coming
because there's other variables at play
does that make any sense no it does
thank you i'm i guess we
all we can do is monitor trends um yeah
okay all right stephen yeah
okay cheryl
um yeah on page 47 it lists the short
stay in the long stay car parks
and it's only got the great torrington
car parks listed as long stay but
actually
they do both i just wanted i think that
was a mistake
that needs to be included on both so
they still get the 30p
for 30 minutes yeah i've actually um
council coca-cola
i've actually emailed both council james
council hurley and councillor hudson
just to confirm that's the case for
sydney and
valley cup yeah that it is 30p
for the first 30 minutes and that's not
going to change and that's not going to
change
okay thanks okay
phil pennington yeah thank you chair uh
just couple points uh town hall
arguments very well put forward by other
other councillors there previously um it
does highlight
the villages actually fund their own
village halls etc etc and there
was in the times it doesn't make any
difference because if you fund it
through the time council or the
district council it comes out the same
equation
for those in the rural areas they are
actually funding the towns
inadvertently and that be born of mine
secondly
i mean we're looking at um in the public
sector little pay rises
you go for the maximum five percent all
the time um
a five pound all the time yeah you're
evan your collection rates looked at no
either 96 or 97 percent
monitor that because i think it may even
go down even further if there is great
pressure on on
the budgets as we come through this
pandemic so it'll be interesting to see
how that comes out as well i think the
public sector which is some of our
highest paid jobs in torridge
are now being restricted um very much
indeed so i'll leave that as a comment
when you think about setting your budget
and this argument about losing money in
the long term
so there we go thank you okay
peter ames yeah just following on the
garden waste and the increased
charges um i can't remember as an
exercise being done
in terms of looking at a three three
weekly black bag collection
in terms of how how much that would save
a net saving or not
i i mean i assume it would lead to more
recycling
so there would be i suppose an increased
cost but then you get
some financial benefit from recycling i
think so um i just wonder if the
exercise has been done
on what possible savings
um i know i know it's on richard's radar
but i certainly i
haven't sat down with a number crunch
that um council hayes with him
i generally would expect it to generate
savings because obviously
you lose the frequency of the um
residual bad collections
so you probably could maybe rationalize
a crew there
and you would like you said you probably
inc you'd pick up more recycling
and hopefully um if we had an
environmental center was
bailing and sorting it you'd expect to
have more tonnage
and you'd get sell more but also for the
duration of the costcard agreement you
would get
um greater caution and recycling credits
from devon county council
because even less would go into landfill
and we share with the benefit of that
but no i haven't sat down with richard
and done that number crunching exercise
will you be um will you be reporting
them any sort of exercise that you do
with richard
can i come in at this point yes you can
um obviously it's not something that the
council has determined
as a policy to take forward to look at
so whilst david
is expressing some of the financial
benefits and so forth it's nothing
members have brought forward through the
strategic plan
to actively consider yet um and i don't
you know and obviously we don't know
whether that's on uh
members minds to consider in the future
so
now there's no plans to bring any
reports forward as yet
because members haven't stipulated that
that's a piece of work
that you want this council to take
forward
i think we just ought to make that clear
at this stage uh just in case any of
these messages are picked up
so i could put down the written i could
put down the motion at council then
to ask for such a report presumably
steve do you want to answer that sorry
um
that's uh no notice emotion up to
individual counselors to determine
what they put forward chair okay and
then it's for council to decide
whether or not to take anything forward
thank you
right anybody else got any questions
is is that richard
where's richard
richard yes did you want to ask a
question
no that's fine that's right no it wasn't
i decided sometimes we just came to
dormant that's okay
all right okay right anybody else got
any questions
don't all shout at once sake
no so are we happy with what david has
put in front of us
yeah yes yeah
yeah everybody yeah
yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean the
excellent report i thought yeah so it's
a lot to take in but yeah
very and joe while you're there just
don't don't leave because i need to just
ask you a question when we're finished
when we go okay and apologies for being
late neighbor with the distress outside
um we've got some recommendations then
yeah can i can i just come in before you
go any further notice the
recommendations we're talking about
uh where are we um
as far as the recommendations go h
increased car parking permits
as detailed in appendix 1 section 3.74
i take it we're not going to discuss
that at this meeting
[Music]
are these the recommendations from
community and resources
these are recommendations on page what
uh sorry on page 34
i'll take this recommendation from this
report
yeah the very last one h increase other
car parking permits charges as detailed
appendix one
capital report section 3.7.4
right i'll take it
are we just going to go for the
recommendation are we going to suspect
can i just come in in there uh i'll put
the
can i just come in there councillor
hurley sorry the record you've got the
recommendations which are from the
report on the screen
and then it says members note the
decisions made by community resources as
detailed below which is essentially
what they um they decided to do which
was to increase the um car parking
charges and the garden waste charges so
on page 34 you've got recommendations
a to d which unfortunately i made a
mistake on my slides i've
called e to h on the slide just to add
real confusion to everybody and i do
apologize for that
okay then it's that members note the
decisions made by community and
resources as detailed below okay
does that clarify chair yes so we're
actually going to look
we're actually looking recommendations a
to d today are we
from the report which have helpfully
entitled e2h
on my slide yeah just to really cause
confusion okay
that was just to check everybody was
awake i do apologize
because i mean i'm not sure if that if
uh when we looked at
when the recommendations h came in i'm
not sure if cnr
realized the implications those
implications of those increases
because they are pretty hefty to be fair
i couldn't comment on um
if cnr understood or not counter hurley
how
i appreciate that david but i'm just
i've looked at them again in more detail
i mean when we talk about putting um the
business permits up 54
in three years and the season tickets 51
in three years it does seem some
somewhat draconian
and when you consider we have just my
view the tourist permits
they are exceptionally cheap for what
they can be obtained
for a permit for you know 30 pound or 25
pounds is going up to
um and looking at a couple of car park
uh charges here
they would save 37 pounds at westwood ho
by buying one in the first year
uh 12 pounds at appledore by the time
they get to the third year
they're saving 44 pounds on the charge
uh in westwood ho 23 pounds
in um appledore it does seem to
this is an academic subject because
these are decisions taken by cnr
and they were not called in within five
days therefore
it's out with uh our uh
discussion at the moment and you know
it's a rabbit hole and i'd suspect we
spent
we're spending quite a lot of time down
rabbit holes this morning um
so uh yeah i don't think it's for our
discussion
it's um somebody else would need to
refer it back to cnr
it's a decision already been taken and
it's been enacted because it wasn't
called in within five days
yeah i appreciate that simon i just
cleared the point and as david's already
cleared
that the last um e28 shouldn't be on
there so that's fine i just want to make
a point on that okay
that's fine that's fine sorry chair
carry on all right
well spotted simon um
okay then so we've got some
recommendations
uh which we have to look at um
[Music]
you know the first one is the uh putting
the council tax up
which i i for one totally agree with um
and do we are we all reading these do we
do we agree with these recommendations
hello are you going to vote with them
all as a whole or individually are you
oh yeah i suggest we do it as a whole
yeah okay i agree
can i have a proposal that we had our
proposal
who's seconding me joe manley
mary can we have a vote on this yeah you
have got a hand up
oh have i oh sorry cheryl
yeah um are we able to add a
recommendation
related to the um the pits
and the notes of motion that we were
talking about earlier no
basically has to go back to cnr but i
thought
so c and r have looked at this and then
i thought it came to us to look at it
and consider and then
it's actually decided by full council so
i didn't think it was for us to call it
in
that was my understanding of it
right steven stevens clarity here please
yeah
so che on the screen you've got um the
four
recommendations for consideration
today um as david says
the council taxer the budget
contributions to reserve and
the the projects identified um
so councillor cottle huntkin is
suggesting
um an amendment to item h
on the screen but item d in your
report pack um so it's
it's whether if comes like all hunting
proposes that amendment
um and members accept it that will go
forward as an amendment to full council
that's the the process this takes
within the within the budget realms so
it's not called in because it comes to
internal scrutiny automatically
right cheryl thank you yeah i was a bit
confused because i
thought that that was the process that
we didn't need to call it in
um because it was coming to us anyway so
i would propose to add to the
recommendations
that um the notices of motion as
detailed in the report so that's for the
pannier market
market house and there's also the one
for the pool cover
um that they're properly
that they're properly reported
considered and debated
following the proper procedures and not
just through the informal workshop
that would be my recommendation if i get
a second one
i would second
okay we need to take a vote that it goes
forward to that
mary yes sir and we have a vote that
uh that that should be added to item d
yes council about and
four councillor cottle hankin
mr dengate or
cancel counselor cup for
councillor haynes or
mr harper paul
councillor hurley or
count to langford for
councillor manly or
councillor newton four
yeah thank you yeah and and you will put
that down for
in in item d mary when the
recommendations go yeah
yes i will chair okay that's fine okay
now we we we need uh
we need to vote on and for for the end
all all the recommendations now
because i think we have a a proposer
simon who was the seconder
councilmember me right okay
same again then mary yep council about
and uh four councillor cottle hankin
for mr dengade or
cancel a cup for
canceling aims
peter wake up oh thank you mr harper
four council hurley
four council language
four councillor manly
four councillor newton
four councillor watson oh
okay unanimous chair yeah thank you very
much
that's great um
what else have we got now then
there's no more uh consideration of the
forward plan now then
okay which is on page
54.
right okay well
did you know we're trying to move the we
we're trying to move the
the meeting on the 23rd to the 16th
because we have two two callings
um one from which involves
one person and one well phil
pennington's already mentioned it
that he's called it anyway but i i
thought
the one that phil called in actually
went to ons
external anyway and so i can't quite
understand why you
you've called it in philly are you still
there phil pennington
no okay then never mind so on that on
okay well joe's here joe joe manley
on the 16th are you are you okay for
any time of the day yeah i'm working
from home
so you can do it in the morning as well
i can yes thank you
okay in that case then uh because jude
can't do it in the afternoon i'm going
to
to say to to you all that we will have
that meeting at 10 o'clock in the
morning
on the 16th okay mary any thanks
thank you mary
hello yes chet that's fine yeah so
that's all sorted out now
so united sorry sorry chair can i just
ask a quick question just so i've got it
clear in my head
yeah does that mean there's gonna be is
there gonna be a meeting on the 16th
and the 23rd not on the 23rd the meeting
is being moved from the 23rd to the 16th
and what will be in that meeting the the
the callings
and the and what's on there in that
meeting
is is what we've got on the on um
our forward plan yeah yeah ubr3 qbr
review
uh update and i'm working and zoom plus
the two plus the coins yeah okay got it
thank you
yeah everybody happy with that yep
okay yeah so really we're done yeah yeah
you have got two names sorry john you've
got two hands up
oh sorry cheryl
go first then yeah i didn't know did we
need to note the
cause we did hd didn't we but we didn't
know eta
h they shouldn't be there cheryl
oh we're not talk so we're not
discussing the car parking
do do we do that at full camp just
they shouldn't be there you got it mixed
up david didn't you
is that what you said sorry i'll just
come back sorry
sorry chet what i was saying was that on
the screen where i had the
recommendations i've
incorrectly labeled them e to hate when
they should have been a to d
as per the report the decision
recommendations for this committee to
make to full council are a to d
from the report which is the council tax
yeah what the net revenue budget and the
contribution to reserves well the
the b and c are in the report are just
they fall out from increasing the
council tax date that's what they become
um you then amended you've had a council
cockle uncommitted proposal to amend the
um item d to have a review of the um
notions of motion yeah and then the
other things
e2h in the report are just for noting
because community as councillor
newton's alluded to community and
resources made that decision to increase
those charges
and they weren't called in within the
five-day period so
there's no re as far as i'm aware
there's no reason to vote on that just
for noting
so exactly there's no need to vote
for them okay is that it you understand
now cheryl
is that set in stone then or can that be
changed by council
okay that's that's a decision made by
cnr
cnr has authority to uh make decisions
on fees and charges which had done so at
this meeting on the 25th
so those fees and charges are now in
place
and uh surely setting up the parking
orders shortly
so they're all in place
okay cheryl
hello yeah okay i didn't realize that
okay right another end peter
peter ames um a couple of questions uh
did you say there's a task and finish
meeting um about qbr
sorry on thursday i can't recall
seeing anything about that okay where
was your at the last one then
i i wasn't out the last one i'm sorry
what sorry it's thursday at what time
sorry
i think it's i don't know john it's one
o'clock i think
it's one o'clock on thursday yes and the
invites have gone out
lunchtime right um the other thing is um
when can we expect um a report on
affordable housing options
is there any progress on that if i can
ask
steve hurst maybe um
chair i'll respond to that's a piece of
work um
john and i and some of the other
officers have been working on
and we'll be updating members shortly
and the we've got ground maintenance in
may on the program
um would that be an opportunity to talk
about the
nature of the contract etc
um we have actually extended the
contract it's all about peter sorry
i think that's why we've got it on yeah
on the
main one okay thank you okay
oh stephen stephen dengate
thank you chair just picking up um on
the
task and finish group we we did discuss
about whether it was something that we
wanted to look at on the forward plan
in regards of reviewing the council's
social value indicators
and whether that might feed into the
kpis in the future
i don't know if this is the time to
mention it or whether we discuss it
thursday
and bring it as a more structured
recommendation i think we should
bring it as a well we'll need it needs
to be a more structured recommendation
to be honest i don't want it to be um
if we've got if all those ducks in a row
then we're fine
so we can do that after
okay anybody got anything else to say
on this before we move on
no is somebody there
no no no that's fine okay
let's um well
our next item on the consideration of
the forward plan
and basically we've just done that and
ended meeting and goodbye and thank you
all for coming
and thank you all for everybody for
watching us on youtube
i'm sure you've enjoyed yourself and
look for